[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to
Halloween is a creepy and subtle classic
be loved by everyone which naturally
means it should be remade by this guy
because he really looks like a dude who
understands subtlety
in 2007 famous rock star Rob Zombie
decided John Carpenter's horror
masterpiece of the master murderer Mike
Myers wacky shenanigans needed a
retelling what disliked by many the
remake did surprisingly manage to get a
little bit of love from fans some
applauded the changes and updates to the
horror stable while others saw it as
gratuitously pointless but to his credit
the fact that's being debated at all is
a testament to the film which would
normally be bludgeoned at the mere
mention of the idea over the years the
film has actually gained some street
cred and I'm here to ask is it warranted
what most people agree the original is
better did sabi actually tap into a
different point of view that was unique
enough to stand on its own did it create
a version that actually does have a
purpose for existing well I'm here to
find out let's give this movie a
stabbing chance with the remake of
Halloween thankfully - the idea that
this is a shot by shot Gus fan suckfest
because the film immediately starts off
different by showing not five minutes of
Michael Myers childhood but 40 minutes
in the two-hour movie no less now some
say this ruins the mystery of what Myers
was like as a kid Hey look at that look
at that no sit it's a freaking remake of
a classic if it didn't do something this
different what's the point of even doing
it but showing more of his childhood
isn't the issue here the issue is
whether or not it's done well in the
original it looked like a middle
American family and Michael for the
short time we saw and seemed like a
normal kid wouldn't makes sense to
really look at Myers as a kid and see
where all of this came from oh it's just
redneck assholes got it we're stuck in
this environment for more than 40
minutes just hammered in our head in the
first two seconds why he's crazy
why don't war look if you told me
someone went crazy hearing Jim Carrey do
that knowing sound from Dumb and Dumber
for over ten years
I believe you we surprisingly don't need
to hear it for 40 minutes
to get the idea we can kind of catch on
but this falls under a genre that Rob
Zombie is something of an expert on
exploitation horror it's meant to be
unpleasant exploitive and extreme in
some respects what the original
Halloween was seen as when it first came
out so you could argue that the
annoyance is part of the idea but Christ
one annoying idea
[Music]
so Michael spends most of his time
hurting things screaming and getting in
pointless fights which is surprising he
doesn't get along with people but see
how every character in this movie is
hurting things screaming and getting
into pointless fights what did you say
fuck mr. principal
his mother is called in - what else
screaming yell I cannot keep coming down
here like this I do not enjoy calling
you down here every five minutes it sure
seems like you fucking do
can I have one day of being a
stereotypical hooker Wow a stereotypical
bad son gets beaten by a stereotypical
drunk dad but groovy dr. Loomis played
by Malcolm McDowell it's a child
psychiatrist who noticed Michael's furry
friends don't like playing with him very
much
typically the thrill of causing pain to
small creatures it's often an early
warning sign early warning sign for what
lady what answer wouldn't be alarming
and then this place for some reason I
[Music]
love the look on Myers face like why is
that playing now do we do anything to
cue it oh my god they must be in the
wrong scene I better run to where the
music makes sense
nope doesn't make sense out here it's
just a kid walking didn't this beam used
to be a big deal like they played over
major moments okay it's dying down now I
guess it wasn't meant to be played over
anything big rather before something big
you go back and read your how to use
halloween-themed manual he beats the
crap out of one of the kids I made fun
of him and returns home to watch better
horror movies sweetie look at me
I know things have been bad but tomorrow
we start to make everything better okay
I'll start by taking one step away from
the camera but not to one step at a time
his sister doesn't take him
trick-or-treating though because she's
too busy making love to her boyfriend
who wears William Shatner masks that's a
stupid thing huh come on baby I want to
do it with the mask on kid how old are
you you're so bored with sex you need to
spice it up already follow-up question
this is spicing it up blah my ears
decides he wants to spice things up too
as he duct tapes his dad and kills him
nothing particularly motivates him to do
it he just decides yeah why not now
never know additional motivation let's
throw the sister in there too the mother
comes home and finds that Michael is
actually a pretty good babysitter just
not a good father sister or boyfriend
sitter
[Applause]
maybe I'll give that psychiatry thing a
try you remember nothing about getting a
knife okay I have to admit there is
something funny about him killing his
family and then lying about it exactly
how a little kid lies but you were
covered in blood
don't believe the fake news both sides
are to blame he seems to be in denial
about killing everyone which again is an
interesting mystery added on top of
everything else how much does he know
and how much is a put-on
fraid you can't go why because you've
done terrible things
no no you're using your malcolm mcdowell
all wrong you're not supposed to let him
act well don't you watch movies you
don't let a great actor like that give a
good performance
put him in shit like tank earlier mr.
Magoo and then we'll talk it is
interesting to see Loomis so sympathetic
hugging Michael comforting him really
trying to help I get why he was so
OneNote in the original it was to build
up the danger of Myers he's not a man
he's a monster and all that stuff but
here he does see him as a child first
it's nice seeing what led up to that
change of heart
stuff like this probably had something
to do with it Meyer seems too dangerous
and unpredictable even leading to his
mother committing suicide so he's locked
away for years and clearly has been
eating his Wheaties don't look at me
I'll be a shitstorm in your worst
nightmare motherfucker you know it's not
uncommon for a director to put himself
in his own films but to wear stilts
Loomis tells Michael that after him not
talking for 15 years he has no choice
but to move on at first he seems really
sympathetic even calling him his best
friend in a weird way you've become like
like my best friend but boy I guess a
crowd really brings out the worst in
people behind these eyes one finds only
blackness yeah previous scene like my
best friend
next scene blackness previous scene
take care night next scene these are the
eyes of a psychopath you sure you're not
the one that needs medicine
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
whenever caretaker's brings Chester a
bum in to have his way with one of the
inmates and they have the brilliant idea
of bringing her into a cell with a
gigantic homicidal maniac this came out
of nowhere
Mya's realizes murder is like Pringles
and he can't stop at just one
he even kills the one guard who treated
him well playing to his unpredictability
Ville honestly I think he just wanted to
stop machete - he realizes his paper
mask should probably be put to rest
so he goes to his old stabbing ground
and grabs his nostalgia goggles
ah the theme actually makes sense in
this scene the witchcraft halfway
through the film were introduced to the
main character of the original lorry I
do like how when she and her friends see
Myers for the first time she doesn't act
scared she instead calls him out hey
Rock is my trigger word
I'm gonna go complain on a blog about
this the rest is can I do what you'd
expect he follows her around they play
the same music and Mayer starts killing
people on Halloween night I got a rock
and stabbed brutally to death evil way
sneaks into other people's houses I like
the fact that he won't kill someone
based on their taste in movies you know
it's a good thing John Carpenter's is
good too but you appreciate the classics
well I do also like that Meyer sneaks up
so well that half the time you don't
even notice him for such an over-the-top
film little touches like that are pretty
cool but don't worry it doesn't get too
subtle Chuckie from child's play shares
a scene with Alex from a Clockwork
Orange I've never seen two people not
trying to be the monster still come
across as the monsters have created
quite the masterpiece of a monster off
the blood of this town I know is in my
bones
then you must promise that you will play
it razor and Amin razor straight with me
these two can do a Christmas show at it
still be terrifying in the clever
combination of Halloween 1 & 2 Loomis
reveals that Myers is after his baby
sister Laurie who we don't want to see
die because she's the closest thing to a
decent human being in this film I said
almost
but Mayer still has to get in some
appetizers before the main course and we
never know what happened to horn this
happens to her we just like holding
shots on doors but fear not there's even
more confusing choices listen to
Laurie's very bizarre dare I say
ridiculously forced backstory after her
mom committed suicide and I see this
beautiful innocent baby sitting in this
little bloody mess
I have knit her from the report I Drive
her to another town and drop her off at
the nearest emergency room and sheriff's
do Christ his manipulation of Theoden
wasn't this crazy to serve and do
whatever the hell you want I guess my
ears finally comes face to face with her
so probably best to have everything on
close-up and shake
it's like I'm really there being shaken
as a baby he knocks her out and takes
her to his old house to show that he's
her brother not entirely sure what he
had in mind but either way she says shit
on that noise and tries to escape you
know this is why men never show
vulnerability around women traps are in
an empty swimming pool a unique spot for
a climax
Palomas shows up to end it all no really
it's totally over you know the rules he
killed the monster once he's never
coming back man you did that so fast you
didn't give me time to finish my joke my
favorite is when McDowell just flat-out
screams what the hell ya know stab him
in the eye or Michael stop just what the
hell is this to say really we're doing
this shit expected more out of something
I already expected less from Loomis
tries to sympathize but Michael helps
him see eye to eye by literally trying
to push his eyes together
Laurie hides inside the house and
honestly does good job because he
literally searches for her for five
minutes yeah five minutes of just
silence and him looking around look I
know you want to build suspense but you
know the same so boring and rather stare
at a wall well Myers is literally
staring at a wall from us at a time I
think more could be done here but it's
okay it's then followed by two minutes
of Myers just stabbing the ceiling
trying to gather it such a thing as
horror movies for plastic lets me feel
like I'm watching
let me guess he's gonna hit the ceiling
I'm a wizard
and what's his great final plan to
finish her off it just runs towards her
she's like dumbass I got a gun she
shoots in she screams that's it
Halloween so um this clearly isn't as
good as the original but I will give it
this it is the second best Michael Myers
Halloween movie but that's coming from a
series that has this circuitry so take
it for what it's worth I know it's
different a little clumsy and arguably
unnecessary but in a strange way I think
it would work less if Zombie didn't
direct it the shock sploit asian-style
has never been my thing but it is a
style that can be done good or bad this
does it good but not great it is a
different direction and sometimes it
does tie into the traditional Halloween
callbacks it's kind of like Halloween
but in an alternate universe the best
stuff is in the mental hospital and
seeing him grow up did make me look at
the killings in kind of a different way
it made me wonder what was going on in
his mind when he was murdering them
while in the original you're concerned
about Laurie survivor it's it miss I
suppose but honestly for a remake of one
of the most famous horror films of all
time hitting this is pretty impressive
it's strange and doesn't always work but
the stuff that does is kind of
interesting take a look and see for
yourself
I'm Anastasia Craig I remember it so you
don't have to
[Music]
[Applause]
hello Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing the
American kidney fund this is the
nation's leading nonprofit working on
behalf of the 30 million Americans with
kidney disease their mission is to help
people fight kidney disease and live
healthier lives and they fulfill that
mission by providing a complete spectrum
of programs and services including
prevention activities top-rated health
educational resources and direct
financial assistance they invest in
clinical research to improve outcomes
for kidney patients and they fight
tirelessly on Capitol Hill for
legislation and policy supporting the
issues that are important to the people
they serve in 2006 they celebrate their
45th anniversary they spend ninety seven
cents of every donated dollar on
programs that directly serve and educate
patients and the public they've also
received the highest ratings from
charity watchdog groups year after year
if you go to their site and their
YouTube channel you can not only see all
the good that they do but also see the
helpful advice that they give in web
seminars on how to treat this illness
they work so hard and they deserve your
support give them a look and figure out
how you can make a big impact in
somebody's life
you